citizens of the reject Nation last night
I couldn't sleep and this is true this
is actually a fact John do you have your
phone I will jump cut to this okay what
do we got you have the YouTube app we
share the same account yeah let's go on
it go to the YouTube history okay do you
know how to access the YouTube history
oh yeah yeah yeah of course not that
history this history where you go to the
history wait of videos that were watched
they moved it where did they move it to
right
there it's early keep going we we going
look what I was watching last night
Kingdom what stop right there look at
that Ryan Gosling funniest moments Ryan
Gosling crashes Russell Crow interview
there are five Ryan Gosling videos when
Ryan Gosling basically won something yes
and because I needed to get my mind into
a better place so I just started
watching some Brian gos videos little
did I know a trailer would be prep
preparing today for a film I have never
heard of that stars Ryan Gosling and
apparently it's a good trailer yeah the
the Gosling signal is high in the sky
it's our duty to check it out if you are
a true fan you you're here I'm excited
man I'm excited I don't know how this
guy can be a dad and work this much and
be so emotionally in tune with himself
he probably needs a lot of help he does
he probably shoulder to lean on and ear
to listen the best John just let me do
it jeez I've learned how to listen from
better help but I don't have the time
right now I'm going to use that promo
code myself to talk about this
experience
right get this off my chest learn how to
communicate better in the
workplace we'll talk more about them
after thanks for sponsoring this video
whoa Emily Blunt back
driving wiant Duke
yeah anyone but him I didn't approve him
you know that why you are literally the
last person on Earth I want to see why
slap the [__] out of you I really could
and I'm open to that and I'm safer
environment my god he has the best
chemistry with all women no phone no
text look at that hair I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame uhoh have you been what have you
done God I hate that thumbs up sty
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this This Man on Fire you're a stunk
guy Man on Fire super profes profes is
my middle name you said your middle name
was
danger this is visually really awesome
yeah really yeah holster that it's
Holsted it's done forget you you never
saw it Oh my God that jumpsuit David
Leech R Go Eric Taylor
John missing you need to bring him back
J's movie is dead why me you're a stump
man nobody's going to notice you that's
your job oh [__] Hanah wanting him too
I'm Tak I love the variety of looker J's
film you get the love of your life back
I'm not the hero I'm just the double not
today you're not oh I've always wanted
to see a movie about the stunt man being
the action hero lead this I've this is
the exact movie for
[Music]
you yep
need that keyless entry
boy dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail
he was super
dead I told you about my dead dad super
dead right go there so many comedies St
I had no choice I had to do something
Jason Bor
[__] stop man becomes the action
here and not in a fun way you're make
you it you yeah make it it's too
dangerous got to be stairs got to be
stairs oh what happened to you face you
look terrible you look
amazing you both look
amazing how far would you go for the one
that you love I love the versatility of
all the looks of this drink when this is
over engage your
core yeah I bet they're going to be a
lot of fun different movie scenarios
what are you doing later want to go to a
beach somewhere drink a spicy Margarita
make some bad decisions
yes oh
wow that's right get crunk dog this
looks like Ryan Gosling
incarnate yeah it's a combination of dry
Place me on the Pines Ken nice guys role
whatever that movie he did with Chris
sevans that was on Netflix
the I forgot what that was called little
bit of Crazy Stupid Love a bit but that
guy's a little bit um you know this guy
seems more of like the down on his luck
kind of fell who doesn't get the
recognition where that guy's like Top
Dog Alpha sure sure sure but you know
there's the Romantic element there's the
Romantic com R goling movie but there's
this is romantic comedy element he's got
the best chemistry with all women all of
them guy like that with so much
heartbreak in his life yeah Lord knows
he needs to consult someone once in a
while dealing with this stuff hey John I
like the Wardrobe changes in this video
you know what I'm going to do I'm going
to change my wardrobe really fast and
emulate a more sincere tone as I talk
about Better Health today so guys I want
to share more thoughts on this trailer
because I got some thoughts that I want
to share and I'm sure John has thoughts
he wants to share too John do you mind
evacuating here for a second sure I
think I should do this solo just like a
therapy session yep yep absolutely
couple section next week today's episode
is sponsored by better help I know that
we often joke around here quite a bit on
the channel but I wanted to speak a
little bit more sincere during this
specific sponsor and I'll start off by
saying this that that you know with any
sponsor they usually give like suggested
things to consider uh when talking about
the sponsor and one of their suggested
things was was a question that they had
there that went along the lines of like
have you ever laid awake with your
thoughts racing wishing for a moment of
silence and I thought to myself well
yeah that's my secret cap like I know
that feeling way too well and it's in
those Quiet Moments where you're
battling your own mind where you are
seeking Clarity the most and you may
have heard me talk about this on the
channel before the better part of a
decade now therapy has undoubtedly been
one of my main anchors before there was
ever the real rejects I was diagnosed
with PTSD type 2 bipolar and ADHD so uh
needless to say I needed some therapy
and through its guidance I've Unearthed
deeper layers of myself cultivated
richer relationships and just have a
more profound understanding of my
emotions and one of the best parts about
it is it's giving me a space where it's
free from judgment where I found my
voice and learned the art of truly
listening not just to others but also to
myself I've talked a little bit about
how this year I've focused a lot more on
my physical health and hitting the gym a
little bit more often and in all
sincerity I do view therapy as like the
a gym for your mental health a place
where you can really nurture your mental
well-being and it is an experience that
has been quite transformative so much to
the point that you know I would say at
least half of the people that you see
that come here on the channel
are in therapy as a matter of fact I
know one of them their therapist is With
Better Health I often joke that like
I've been in therapy since it was
underground why I joke like that is
because I I see now in the past few
years a lot more people have been going
to therapy which is fantastic i' love
seeing that so I will say that if in
your heart if you have been seeking
therapy or contemplating going to
therapy I highly encourage you I urge
you to consider better he before I ever
saw some ad for better help I had heard
other people who had been with better
help and had really given strong
in-person testimonies to me their online
platform is crafted with care keeping
your comfort in mind starting it as
simple as answering a few questions and
really important to remember it's a
journey and I really love this because
I've had at least like three therapists
in my life so if you ever feel the need
to change your therapist better help
understands and allows it without any
fuss trust me that's a massive benefit
so for a journey of self-discovery and
mental well-being turn to better help
embark on this heartfelt Joy at
betterhelp.com that's
R 10% off your first month genuinely
thank you to better help for sponsoring
this video all right I'm back John
you're back we're all back yeah thank
you guys you know signing up for better
help using R link that also does help
with um you know bettering yourself
bettering yourself and then bettering
the channel and they know and that's
just awesome but mainly look out for
yourself uh yeah I like I really I
really love this trailer a lot like this
just looks like a genuine Classic Fun
time and David
Leech coming onto the scene with John
Wick which that first one had some of
the most humor out of the four films
that came out and I think that when he
left to direct his own movies he said I
want to do the comedy side yes and then
CH H's like I'm going to do the like
dark copile side yeah I'm going to keep
this going you do your Hobs and Shaw and
your bullet train and your Deadpool I'm
going to play to the film students you
catch the clex the Megaplex yeah yeah
and this looks like he's it seems like
it's taking a while because I like I
like bullet I think we both like bullet
train uh and even though this is just a
trailer there's something about this
that does seem that perhaps this could
be his sharpest most confident one of
them all like I love the versatility to
it
it the other movies have always at least
even just from the marketing standpoint
have reminded me of other works and this
seems like oh there's a there there's a
a voice of his own attached to this one
yeah yeah where I wouldn't really say
that with the other films like you can
liken this to other there even a film
back in the day called the stunt man and
while I can liken Ryan gos like like
writing wise and storywise but visual
wise and even the comedic sensibilities
of this all like I I really loved um
just the production design all around I
feel like the action will be really cool
I love this kind of main character you
get a root for as well like I I I used
to want I I had the idea for it remember
that mission impossible MTV sketch the
Tom Cruz one with Ben Stiller where
played something like that's when I
thought of that idea of there should be
a movie where like the I remember you
mentioning this my idea I'll just say it
now even though this is not the plot
here um and now this is my way of
copyrighting the idea is putting out at
the public forone to think was that the
stunt man and the action hero are very
close with each other like he's always
his stunt double because that's usually
how a lot of these relationships work
with leading man and stunt double what
an irony sense because you know that
Ryan gossing had a stunt double for
doing these stunts
yes but but what would happen in my
movie is that the action hero would get
kidnapped like a celebrity kidnapping
and the stunt man would R to the
occasion to go save him so he finds
himself in like a real life action movie
having to go save him and you see that
he's the real hero the hero that doesn't
get all the credit on screen so that was
my my idea and that's not exactly what
this is at all actually um but
regardless I I have been drawn to like
it should do an action comedy where the
stuntman is the lead and that is what we
were getting here and I think Ryan
Gosling looks uh excellent and sorry
John I've just been in therapy so I'm
going to real talkative mode right now
right you got to get it all out there
get all out make the most of the time no
I enjoyed this trailer too I feel like
this is the kind of movie that that
could go one of two ways in that it does
look like the most distinct David Leech
movie trailer because yeah like other of
his movies have you know hearkened to
other directors and things like that
it's like you know Atomic blonde
hearkens to certain other things or a
bullet train hearkens like guy Richie
you know whereas this I feel like
certainly seems like an opportunity for
him to prove what his signature blend of
action comedy and scope would be I could
see if this doesn't go quite right it
being maybe a tonal mess uh if it
doesn't click together but I think it
has enough assets to its name and David
Leech is a solid enough director who I
think has learned each time around uh
enough that it gives me confidence that
this will turn out to be as as fun as it
looks because too you know like not this
isn't going for the broadness of tone
necessarily that that like a Tropic
Thunder is but it seems to present a
similar kind of fun Prospect of we're
going to get a lot of behind the scenes
sort of in the no film making style
ribbing of the process but also the
blurring of the lines between you know
the real world versus you know like
movies style Stakes becoming real world
and things like that and you have like
so many different people on this cast
and you have what looks to be one main
sort of in movie Universe movie but also
the potential for you know many others I
think presents itself as well which is
always a fun thing for me is seeing like
what you know there there could easily
be a montage of like all the different
stunts and and movies this guy's done
and all the different roles he's had to
take and stuff because he's like mainly
the one we see is him as this like
futuristic space you know cowboy type
thing like Cowboys versus Aliens kind of
character or something like that um and
and so yeah like this looks really fun
and like it could be David leech's
opportunity to play to the film students
but in that fun popcorn kind of
sensibility because you're able to bring
in such a wide swath of references and
influences like I totally agree and you
know not to mention too it's Emily Blunt
is a phenomenal actress uh I I I hear
arguments that sometime sometimes I
agree with it that she is probably
the best actor working today um you know
like I'm not saying she is like the
greatest of all time I think she was one
of the greatest though like she can do
any genre she can be it's even looking
at an action movie she could be a badass
lead Action Hero like in edge of
tomorrow and then be this character sure
who is the who is not the action hero
but still like a leader on set I hope
that her talents are utilized well um I
love seeing see Ryan Gosling pair up
with whatever leading actress he's
pairing up with because his odds of
generating great chemistry with them are
always very very high uh I think he
knows how to connect with actresses
extremely well because I think they want
to connect with him and who doesn't I
would man I would toally leave my wife
from Ryan Gosling and and Aaron Taylor
Johnson as you know after working on
bullet train with him to come back here
and I feel like they David Leech really
gave him a character and bullet train
that allowed him to uh really stretch
and I think that getting some Aaron
Taylor Johnson roles peppered in that
show a lot more of his versatility
before we see Craven I think it's an
exciting prospect for him in his career
Endeavors you know um and I really like
this trailer a lot I thought this was a
really fun looking trailer the only real
concern I have about it if I'm being
totally honest is that I feel like it
might be uh it might fall into the Trap
fall and might fall into the Trap of
being excessive and way tooo [__]
long you know
than we having with it yeah yeah I think
every T Leach movie has this problem
where we go on for like way too long
let's get that
245 yeah like we don't need to be around
this long man you're ruining the fun
bring it in at a tight 90 hour 45 I
think I think keeping this like just
under two hours is totally totally fine
like an hour 50 minute run time my
concern is that when I go to buy tickets
it's going to say like 2 and a half
hours like Jesus Christ David Le like
dial it back Cutting Room floor love
yourself too much yeah that that is my
one one concern um but hey what did you
guys think about this trailer were you
surprised did you think you were
clicking on a video game trailer cuz
that's what I thought it was the first I
saw the title like here's Universal
milking that Mario franchise and now
we're doing a completely different game
oh no this is
not um leave your thoughts down below uh
what you all think thank you to better
help and hey we will catch you all on
the flippity flip see you
[Music]
guys